we're talking about halo yakuza and
final fantasy 14. all on today's save
state gamespot's big old news show
with me your host curtin davina for
wednesday july 22nd
welcome
[Music]
we got a look at the halo infinite box
art and well it looks a whole lot like
the halo combat evolved
box art now and something else stood out
to us is that a grappling hook
on master chief's arm there's already
been quite a bit of speculation
surrounding the grappling hook since
footage
leaked in february but we still don't
truly know
we might get to see more tomorrow during
the xbox series x
live stream which will be happening at
9am pt and
will supposedly be focusing quite a bit
on halo infinite we're also going to be
having a pre
and post show with our very own lucy
james tamora hussein
and michael hyam so come back then to
check it out
get excited with us yakuza lego dragon's
been out since january in japan but we
finally got a worldwide release window
and it's gonna be accompanied with
english voice acting
the game is coming out in november for
ps4 xbox one xbox series x and pc
and is also coming to the ps5 but at a
later date
now we don't have the specific date but
the microsoft story lists it for xbox
and pc
for november 13th and it's
safe to possibly speculate that that may
or may not be the day in which the xbox
series x launches
we'll see traditionally the yakuza games
have always had japanese voice acting
accompanied with english subtitles but
this time it's getting the full english
dub
treatment which is new to the series the
game judgment made by the same studio
did also get this treatment but this is
the first time in a mainline
yakuza game and the cast is pretty
impressive
including one particular oh my
george takei which in of itself is
pretty damn exciting
final fantasy 14's free trial is about
to get a whole lot
bigger with the 5.3 patch coming
this august 11th the new trial will
include the entire base game and its
first expansion
heaven's word new players can access all
of that content
all the way up to heaven words and game
that leads into the following expansion
stormblood that means access to 13
classes and jobs and a level cap of 60.
previously the trial only included the
base game with the level cap of 35.
some in-game features will be restricted
but this new trial essentially makes the
base game and heavensward a free-to-play
mmo okay that's it for news but we still
have one more thing
to talk about and that is gamespot's
merch store that's the place where you
can buy
this poster a hoodie like this a
skateboard face mask and many other
things
until the end of august all of its
proceeds will be split up between black
lives matter and coven 19 relief so
go and check it out if your heart
desires a link will be in the
description
below okay that's it for today's news
but of course you can find out about
everything i just talked about by going
to gamespot.com
again i'm current divina thanks for
joining me stay well
drink water just be cool be nice
alright till next time
you